hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I am your host
flying solo this week Mark Ellis but I
won't be alone for long because I'm
about to be joined by sort of my twin I
don't actually have a twin say fraternal
somebody I was born with but uh there's
only so many faces in the world and me
and our guest today both got blessed
with the same face that would of course
be Topher Grace who is going to be
joining us as we talk about Back to the
Future the entire Trilogy is what we're
covering today we're going to go through
the classic first one how we feel about
Back to the Future two and three as well
he's a huge Back to the Future fan and
he's got his new show uh home economics
which is now entering its next season
he's both the executive producer and one
of the Stars so talking to him about
that all of his his great movie roles
That 70s Show I mean he was in
everything from Black landsman to
predators to Spider-man 3 I mean the
guy's done a lot of stuff win a date
with Ted Hamilton I mean come on Topher
Grace is here and I will probably get a
chance to ask him uh if he remembers our
fateful meeting for the very first time
at a certain restaurant in Hollywood
um but uh very excited to be joined by
him uh Jacqueline Coley's still out on
the road I believe she's a tiff right
now the Toronto International Film
Festival so while we look back on some
great movies she is seeing some new
great movies and uh at the end of the
show if we have time might very quickly
bring in our esteemed engineer Brian
Perez because he has some hot takes
about Back to the Future I'd like his
thoughts on so if we have time we'll get
to that
um Back to the Future you know him you
love him Marty McFly is just a kid in
1985 when all of a sudden him and his
scientist buddy Doc Brown accidentally
sort of get transported back to 1955
well Marty does any meat stock in 1955
and then he has to get back to 1985 and
then if in the second one he goes to
2015 take care of some issues there gets
back to 1955 after going back to an
alternate 1985 then we go back to 1885
and then we go all the way back to 1985.
there's a lot of time jumping in this
movie courtesy of a semi-nuclear-powered
DeLorean and it's just one of those
movies that I don't know if you ever can
remake it I know that you never should
get topher's thoughts on that as well so
all of that and more coming up right now
on the podcast Back to the Future with
Topher Grace but first we left room for
our favorite segment here on the show
Tim Ryan our review curation manager
here at Rotten Tomatoes is going to tell
us what the critics were saying at the
time of Back to the Future one two and
threes release now I didn't run down the
Tomato meters yet I'm going to let Tim
do that uh Tim I'm hoping that the first
one is very very very high on the Tomato
Meter take it away
moments with him it's been more than 30
years since the final entry hit theaters
and there have never been any major
attempts at reboots or remakes so why
does it back the future trilogy still
resonate so strongly I think it's that
it almost miraculously Blends its many
seemingly discordant elements into
something so light and at the same time
as Marty McFly would say so heavy it's a
teen comedy and a sci-fi film and it's
got great characters and endlessly
quotable dialogue and Incredibly tense
action set pieces and hilarious
throwaway visual gags and a terrific
score it's also a poignant meditation on
family and Community through the
generations and in the case of part two
the best movie ever made based on the
science of time travel at least
according to the legendary scientific
polymath Carl Sagan so let's take a
quick look at the three entries Back to
the Future from 1985 is certified fresh
at 97 on the Tomato Meter with 86
reviews and it has a 94 audience score
Back to the Future Part 2 from 1989 is
fresh at 63 percent and it has an 85
audience score Back to the Future Parts
three from 1990 is certified fresh at 80
with 46 reviews and it has a 78 audience
score so what do the critics have to say
in a fresh review of the original Joseph
gelmis of Newsday wrote Back to the
Future is the best comic strip movie
I've seen this year it's well made
light-hearted and is exactly the right
length to give you excitement and laughs
and a few surprises and then it's over
leaving you feeling good however in a
rotten review for Back to the Future
Part Two Jonathan Rosenbaum with the
Chicago Reader wrote by the end you may
feel that you've just sat through a
future length commercial for both part
one which has to be seen to make this
sequel comprehensible and part three a
trailer for it literally ends part two
so that's the Back to the Future Trilogy
let's kick it back to Mark I'm gonna
make like a tree and get out of here
there's Tim Ryan and without further Ado
let's get into some movie Talk Back to
the Future Trilogy with Topher Grace
[Music]
and now as promised welcoming to the
show for the very first time Mr Topher
Grace the executive producer and star of
home economics you also know him from
award-winning movies Blockbuster sitcoms
anything and everything on stage on
screen and his podcast minor adventures
with Topher Grace welcome sir I
apologize if it feels like you're
looking in a mirror well that only means
that you're a very good looking man
this was this was the weirdest
interaction that I had because it was
also so pleasant this was you will not
remember this about 10 years ago I was
with some friends at a Chipotle in
Hollywood and you were right in front of
me and I never had already just what you
said means you probably bumped into me
yeah we ordered the exact same burrito
toefer I wasn't trying to copy you we
got to look at each other and did like a
mirror exercise I was nervous to shake
your hand because you were very gracious
I said that you know hey a lot of my
fans say I look like you as a cool you
take a picture you were very very nice
and I was concerned when we actually
shook hands that it was going to be like
time cop where the space-time Continuum
just turns the matter inside of itself
luckily that's not the time travel
reality well it's funny you get that but
I get Brad Pitt a lot and it's like it's
been detrimental in my career because
it's like you know I'm My Own actor you
know what I mean like it's I'm only
getting roles that he passed on and you
go when do I get to become my own person
the hell that is our life I think we we
would have looked great on that roof
fixing that antenna in Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood so maybe the next time yeah
it was either him or me or you it's like
interchangeable
um something that is not interchangeable
that is just a part of uh really
Americana and really beloved worldwide
is the Back to the Future Trilogy of
movies and I will say particularly the
first one and I don't want to be a
naysayer towards the sequels they're
very fun movies but we're here to talk
about the entire Trilogy so I'm just
going to run down the Tomato Meter score
with you and I just want to get your
take as to whether Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong with any of these so Back to the
Future from 1985 the classic 97
certified fresh 94 audience score I'll
tell you that is off by about three
percent
I mean I don't think and that's always
you know like I remember going back and
reading the Time Magazine review of Star
Wars which was like terrible and then
they had to retract it and literally
print an article saying we were wrong
like just the reviewer was having an off
day or or didn't get it or something but
I think there's no one that's that's
from 1985 those reviews you're talking
about right that's from 1985 until now
because I mean you can really look at it
like okay this is a lot of movie
reviewers at the time but then a lot of
newer movie reviewers that are on the
Tomato Meter go back and look at these
movies I have a feeling that anything
that is not a hundred percent or nothing
that is from 1985 right yeah that's got
to be in 1985 some I don't want to say
Karachi I don't want to demographic it
you know say who it was but it just felt
like maybe it like the movie says itself
if you don't like it your kids are gonna
love it
that's right that's that's right I uh
yeah I think I can understand how
someone older at the time might have
thought that it I mean because it was
really made for uh for kids I mean for
teens I mean but I remember seeing it my
experience without film is seeing it one
of the first movies I remember seeing
with my parents like everyone seemed
excited to see it and my sister right so
that was a wide
swath of people of different ages and I
remember us all enjoying like going oh
man this is crazy that I'm uh you know
eight or nine or something and my dad is
40 something and we're both enjoying it
like that's very rare I mean truly
enjoying something that's fascinating so
you actually did get to see the movie in
in a theater when it came out and you
like remember that experience yeah I was
just old enough that I remember they I
was like uh with a babysitter and my dad
came home and was talking to the
babysitter like everyone says this
movie's it was the first like
Blockbuster I was aware of people were
talking about and then when I saw it I
mean look this is not a unique situation
anyone listening who's my age probably
had this experience but immediately I
had to buy a skateboard it was like that
scene with the skateboard at the
beginning was and immediately we had to
buy like an LP of that uh of that Huey
Lewis song I was the same way uh albeit
I guess I was a little younger because I
didn't see the first movie in the
theater I think this was the rare movie
where my parents broke down and they're
like everybody's talking about this
we're gonna get a babysitter for the
three kids and we're gonna go see if
it's okay and they came back and they
told us about it and so then the next
year when it was like available to tape
on VHS it was that and Teen Wolf were
like constantly played at my house yeah
Michael J fox had a big year in 1985.
those those were my sports I like I was
like okay well I need to learn how to
skateboard and I need to learn how to
play basketball and if I get to turn
into a werewolf on time and you need to
learn how to do flips on top of your van
we did do wait don't don't try it at
home kids that's all I'm gonna say what
you see oh yeah I have a friend who says
about movies
um who's in the business out here he
says all movies are allowed one thing so
like a kid becoming a wolf
you're you go okay that's the premise
but when he starts break dancing you're
like this is unrealistic
yeah it's like it's the Indiana Jones
fridge bomb it's like I'll let that
happen but the rest of the movie better
be realistic the the fridge oh yeah you
know you're right I was like a judge
when I saw you're talking about the
Crystal Skull the kingdom of the Crystal
Skull yeah when I saw that opening I was
like a judge who's like I'll allow it
but I want to see where this is going
you better be going somewhere with this
counter yeah you better be going
somewhere with this uh attorney whatever
yeah it was uh it was just a
transcendental movie and then you had
the two follow-ups that were pioneering
movie technology as far as visual
effects and also how to make movies
being shot back to back that was Back to
the Future too from 89 which is 63
percent fresh on the Tomato Meter and
then back to the future three gets back
up to 80 percent certified fresh the
interesting thing about those two movies
is that Back to the Future 2 actually
has the higher audience score which is
85 percent yeah I was gonna say I think
if you ask most people they'd say the
films go in order of uh how good they
are is that how you feel about matter
because I go I go one and then I go
three and then I go to
I actually don't disagree with you but I
think that the most people I've talked
to
don't like three I kind of thought three
was charming and two's like uh a little
challenging
um but uh look the first movie alone is
probably the most perfect film ever made
it's just so like there's not one line
that doesn't connect to
another line except when he's pouring I
mean I'm gonna geek out real hard at
this please do when he pours those chips
you know he pours that peanut brittle
yeah that's the only I remember back
even when I saw it the first time being
like why did they do like a hard cut to
him pouring peanut brittle did you want
to talk about so George McFly at dinner
yeah is it dinner out of nowhere there's
a hard cut and he's just like going to
town on this peanut brittle and it's
because there's a a scene they were
right to cut after Biff leaves someone
shows up selling the equivalent of like
Girl Scout cookies but it's peanut
brittle and she just she's like do you
want peanut brittle and the dad just
says to the Girl Scout like yeah just
sign him up for like 20 boxes right
George like it just shows how much he's
like being pushed around and that's to
me the only thing that's imperfect about
the movies that they cut out I never
understood why he was going to town on
that peanut brittle but I always thought
as a kid I always thought it was just
like this weird cereal that adults eat
and then you come to realize no that's
peanut brittle that George McFly is
eating but it's also that scene itself
is such a great intro into the family
Dynamic just how boring they are and as
a kid though you you're accepting films
especially at that age when we probably
saw it you're accepting films on a dream
like level so you're not asking
questions because I grew up I thought
this script I mean there's literally not
one line
that doesn't connect to a thing that
pays off except for that peanut brittle
thing which was probably the right cut
to make I I heard a um a DVD commentary
thing with uh zemeckis talking about
testing this film
which is just the greatest story ever
which is like if everyone who went to
see this film our parents included had
watched all the ads and understood the
conceit of the movie but when you test a
movie
uh they don't tell you the conceit I
mean I've been to film tests you know as
both an actor and beforehand when I was
in college I went to The Truman Show
weirdly and I had no idea what The
Truman Show I knew it was a film
starring Jim Carrey and then you start
watching it and it kind of explains
itself at the beginning like oh Truman
is in a community and he's being filmed
but back to the future if you haven't
seen an ad for it is a very weird first
20 minutes it's a strange movie
particularly if you only really know if
your entry point if you're in that test
audience you probably knew Michael J fox
from Family Ties and you enjoyed him as
Alex P Keaton but seeing this time
travel move it's like what the hell is
this movie you don't even know it's
about time shot first it's this no it's
like playing guitar then he's in school
then his family is doing like an info
dump of like how they met which you
don't really care about then a mad
scientist has a time machine I mean it's
like what they said about I mean I think
it's one of the highest rated test films
tested films of all time like it's just
such a crowd pleaser but
uh apparently like there were a couple
walkouts at the beginning
because no one understood where it was
going or what the it was just it's so
Meandering at the beginning and
apparently when they're both putting
their hand on the back of their head him
and his dad and they look you know the
guy says McFly and they look up together
the whole audience in unison went oh
like they they understood the thing that
the ads would tell you
why
what do you think you're doing
yeah
hey I'm talking to you McFly you Irish
bug oh hey Biff hey guys how are you
doing you got my homework finished McFly
you know what I mean which was that
great what the whole thing is and then
it became like everyone stayed but the
fact that a couple people walked out I'm
like yeah I get it you're kind of like
what is this film about if you don't
know the the other great story is he his
editor Artie Schmidt who's just one of
the great editors he was gonna zemekis
was gonna cut out the Johnny Be Good
soon travesty which and they said the
editor was a great editor just said why
would you leave it in for the first test
screening let me see what it looks like
in front of an audience because he had
to know what they had there because I
was going to ask you what what is your
favorite scene in Back to the Future I
mean you take this perfect movie and you
just condense it into this is the scene
that really lights it up for me for me
it is it's the Johnny B Goode scene
that's still I had the pleasure of of
doing a q a and like introducing the
movie a few years ago and then it like
you know sometimes you'll do a job and
then you're like all right what's
um it was it was a it was a q a at a uh
a company used to work for called
collider and so we didn't have any of
the it was we didn't have any of the
cast and crew we just had like doing a
interview with me about a movie that I
was literally nobody affiliated with the
film whatsoever and here's how great
Back to the Future is it was still a
packed house right they knew that they
weren't getting
famous person there but they still were
like no we want to go see Back to the
Future yeah and then when the when the
Johnny B good scene happens which I
guess you know usually on the show I
want to give you some context if you
haven't seen Back to the Future I highly
recommend it yeah just stop listening
immediately and go watch that movie with
your time if you like peanut brittle
this is the movie for you that's how
we'll sell it if you haven't also if you
you probably don't listen to the rest of
the podcast if you've never seen it but
uh
I think that's uh I mean just an example
of it growing up the more you watch it
the more you learn about uh uh structure
and what should pay off but what's so
interesting about the Johnny Goods scene
is zemeckis was right like it actually
has nothing to do with the plot and you
don't need it and I try to remember that
um even it's so funny we were editing uh
episode of home economics and the best
moments of any I mean this is only a 22
minute long thing but the best moments
of anything are when it kind of leaves
the ground for a second and you do
something that that doesn't necessarily
have a payoff like the thing in itself
is a payoff or it's just kind of like uh
encapsulating the feeling of the we've
gotten better at that as we've gone
along where we go like our Premiere
episode we go to Disneyland
and just beforehand I uh it's not in the
script but like how much can we film
there's a moment where my brother and I
go off and
ride the rides and it's it can't really
be scripted you know it's just kind of
like they go on rides and have fun there
were a couple jokes that we scripted in
like a montage but I thought how much
footage can we get
of that you know what I mean that
feeling that you're at when you're at
Disneyland and and uh not to compare it
at all to Back to the Future or the
Johnny B good scene but the best stuff
is when the music kicks in I mean every
movie that that you love probably has a
moment that could be cut out but is
actually the best moment and just you
can't describe why I mean there's not
even any dialogue you know with Back to
the Future I'm gonna say I'm gonna cry
foul I'm gonna say that it does have
something to do with the plot and I'll
I'll put my finger in zemeckus's face
and say that the beauty of that scene is
that this is Marty real because I mean
the movie is it's also about Marty's
journey and whether he wants to be or
whether he can pull up being a musician
whether he believes in himself enough
because the beginning of the movie he's
auditioning to play at a day at a school
dance
actually I think Marty is such an
interesting character and he's like so
indicative of the 80s which is he's not
even the star of the film he's just a
cool guy like they tacked on this thing
there's like 100 two scenes it gets
rejected from like you know playing at a
dance but truly the protagonist of the
film is George it's like he's got yeah
this you know he's gotta overcome his
obstacles and ask the girl out and beat
up the guy and like his son's just the
coolest dude from 1985 who knows
skateboard tricks and I mean I'm not
besides kind of like playing that song
Marty has almost no growth during the
film but I but I I mean that's what's so
cool about the 80s there were characters
that were just cool yeah it doesn't
really matter like if Marty's left to
his own devices hey he's never getting
out of 1955 if he goes back there but it
really is Doc Brown pushing him the
whole time like you need to do this you
need to be here at this point you need
to do this and then that's how you're
going to get back to your time yeah and
then he's trying to push the dad to grow
and at the end the dads have this huge
growth and I would say if the Tomato
Meter is correct the second and third
ones really kind of suffer from not
having the the protagonist from the
first one in it and can I just add I'm
dying to put this in a film I want to
I'm not going to do any action films
so I don't know how this would work but
I want to do a scene where I'm like
jumping out of a plane or something and
right beforehand instead of saying like
you know see on the ground or you know
whatever the cool line is I want to say
all right listen it's a blues riff and B
watch me for changes and try to keep up
and then jump out of the plane
I was gonna say was that not like a cut
scene from predators where like like you
wake up or you're you know they didn't
want any uh any back to the future
references in that Predators I guess
that's a bummer because Predators just
on a different note I will say as good
as any other Predator moving the
franchise fresh on the Tomato meat I
know praise prey is pretty great is
pretty sweet Contracting Bird friend and
he is uh he just crushed it with that
film I loved it yeah really really
um getting back to back to the future
what's the what's another scene that's
not it's not the Johnny B good scene
where again the hair stands up on my
arms when it when it comes on I love it
so very much
um the other one for me would be the
first time we go back in time we're at
Twin Pines mall and it's an adventure
scene and it's just Marty and when he
shifts and and he escapes the van and he
says let's see if you bastards can do
90. it just that to me we're watching a
gear shift happen in the movie that's
also when the movie itself takes this
metaphorical gear shift that just gets
us to the next level terms of excitement
in terms of wow what a ride we're on
let's see a few bastards can do 90.
[Music]
the other thing I've heard when zemekis
talks about it is there are very few
visual effects in the first one the
second one takes more advantage of you
know Robert's mattress is amazing uh
ability to work with with I think it's
the first one he worked with computer
effects which has become like his thing
right yeah but like that first one it's
really the story that's the effect or
it's the changing of sets and you know
you're looking at the same town square
but it looks different there's really
like
two special effects shots or maybe three
I guess there's the hand you know when
he's playing uh guitar and there's the
the car twice to me it's like the
tension in that film you know I mean I
love that the scene you're talking about
obviously is unbelievable but the last
scene when he's I mean I remember seeing
the it's like maybe my 15th time seeing
the film and your heart is in your
throat like is the thing gonna connect
with the lightning and then the plug and
I mean it's like each time that he has a
solution then then there's another
bigger problem and then when it all
works it's like I think the the original
beginning of the end of the film was he
had to fly into a nuclear bomb that was
going off in the desert that was like
and I think it's because of budgetary
stuff that they
had to like scrap it but I think it
forced them to do something that was
more probably less effects driven but
more actually tension driven which is
put it in that in that square at
Universal and it's just like a oh my God
that's just such a perfect scene and
that oh my God I just I can't talk about
it without just geeking out I just love
it so much no I mean it's also like the
performance if you look at it from an
actor's point of view like it's bananas
everyone's doing like Kabuki theater
it's way I mean like if I walked I get
like why Eric Stoltz was fired he's
probably doing a pretty normal good job
but like sure everyone's like at the
very least everyone's doing sitcom
acting you know it's like the guy from
Taxi the guy from Family Ties I mean
it's like what George is doing I mean
it's like it's so the The Genius of it
is the conductor has them all doing it
at the same level you know what I mean
like everyone's uh over the top at the
exact same level it's probably why
they're she'll uh didn't work work out
when I look at it I go I think I learned
more about timing for That 70s Show or
for any sitcom from watching that movie
because they literally pause for
for like audience laughs yeah you know
like you would never in real life say
listen dad dad
IO like if you're trying to like hide
the fact you're saying dad you wouldn't
like say it out loud but everything's
like uh it's all at the same level it's
brilliant that's why we got to show it
that you George McFly are a fighter
you're somebody who's gonna stand up for
yourself somebody who's gonna protect
her yeah but I've never picked a fight
in my entire life
look you're not gonna be picking a fight
dad
dad Daddy-O
you're coming to a rescue right the wine
that I quote myself that I quote back to
myself the most is like when I'm talking
to nobody else in particular I just love
saying the line Jesus George it's a
wonder I was even born why would you say
that out loud your dad you're about to
give it away man it's like
if you want a real treat is Type in
YouTube Crispin Glover Family Ties
because two years before he was on
Family Ties
and here's the thing about Crispin
Glover because you've heard so much
there's so much drama about him on the
film and why they didn't want to have
him the sequels and stuff but he's
hilarious in Back to the Future I mean
he's amazing and he if you watch him on
Family Ties he's like stealing the
scenes from Michael J fox he's great I
mean he's great I you know it's like
this episode without a strip club or
something but like
he's just crushing lines and he's he's
coming from Neptune like you like you
would never make the choices he makes
and so funny it's it's a credit to his
ability as an actor and I guess his
range is an actor because you know you
talk about watch this movie as a kid and
certain things you don't notice
particularly about a performance is how
you know how versatile he is going from
the guy that we meet in 1985 to being a
30-year younger version of that same guy
and pulling it off and then coming back
to 1985 and being the polar opposite of
who he originally was yeah I love how
cool he is it's all believable too and
Leah Thompson's I mean like amazing like
yeah they don't get focused on enough
how great they are in that movie and the
villain the villain presence of business
yeah man he's got to be like top five
villains of all time right he is I mean
because you talk about this movie and
and you look at how Biff wants to be
with the rain and and how problematic
that might have been in retrospect with
any other movie but this is one of those
where it doesn't really really it just
never really enters my head space in the
same way that the time travel mechanism
itself I don't none of this matters that
it's realistic or not because you're
having such a good time from start to
finish with this movie that it doesn't
matter if it checks all the scientific
boxes and with Biff your Biff is so
funny and he's in 1985 he's the bully
and it's another one of my favorite
lines it's Jesus I pay to have your car
towed all the way to your house
no that's like I didn't get that when I
was a kid and as an adult when you watch
it you go what a brilliant line
he's like he's having such a blast with
that role it's like I have it sometimes
on home economics when we're here you
know I got to be a producer on it uh
which is my first time producing a TV
show so and and the only reason I really
wanted to do that was to have a say in
the cast because you know what like a
movie
you know this goes on and on and on
we're entering our third year of doing
it and I've been on a TV show like that
before and I've been with a real kind of
dream team and I thought I just want to
be part of um helping choose those
people because you wind up spending a
big chunk of your life with them I mean
you need them to be good as actors but I
really wanted to be people that I was
all like
like like crazy fan a fan of like I just
like I mean I would say the same thing's
true about all great ensembles like
everyone's crushing it uh but uh I'm
looking at the poster here we're all
like I just yeah I feel the same way
when I'm watching movies I love you just
wanna sometimes I miss my lines on home
economics because I'm sitting here going
like you're watching their performance
and saying like yes oh that's gonna cut
together so great I'm like fine yeah no
no no I forget it to me I'm just gonna
okay there's been a long pause it's
probably my turn now you know you make
such an interesting point about the Back
to the Future films and and and I would
say this for the whole trilogy is that
Marty McFly is the cool one but it's
even though the two and three become
more about his story he it's so crucial
to have that surrounding Caster talking
about particularly Christopher Lloyd's
Doc and Thomas F Wilson as Biff back in
the old days in 2015 I mean Back to the
Future 2 comes out and so over I still
look at that movie as like the gold
standard for what the future could have
been because every movie we see now with
the future it's dark it's depressing
there's no water left back to the future
too was and it was it came out in 89 or
night and I saw that in the theater that
was my first theater experiences wow and
2015 was still far enough away to be
like this could actually happen this is
exciting well I think they were I look
at it now and I realize I think they're
kind of trying to do the 50s in the
future like they kind of color wise they
did something really great with the
first one I heard that they all the
paint on the buildings was actually
colors from cars at the time it wasn't
actually the 50s it was like um this is
Rick Carter I think uh it was like a
great production designer came up with
that idea of like giving it this Sheen
that I mean at the time it's so sad at
the time when I saw it we were closer to
1955 than we are now to
1985. but like I mean my parents said
they were watching the film going oh
that's when I grew up but it was this
um you know Mr Sandman like you know
like uh idealized version of the 50s and
the colors were you know popped more and
it was kind of a little cleaner it was I
don't know America's idea of what the
50s were and then I think the future was
kind of a version of that uh I think I
heard Bob Gale say once that it was like
like just do gags like they because you
can't really say you can comment on the
past but they were just trying to kind
of do you know fun gags like the you
know instead of people coming out wash
your car a robot comes out and watched
it or just you know funny future gags
but I think the joke you know the the
shark in 3D or the USA Today the
newspaper stuff like that the what was
really appetizing to me who was on the
side of chubby as a kid is the tiny
little Pizza Hut that you put in the
oven and then it just makes a huge he I
was like is that really the this is good
the future's gonna be great yeah well it
felt kind of like a soda pop Fountain
Shop version of the of the future you
know which no one does you're right the
weirdest scene to me and I think you'd
probably agree is just when we go to the
McFly's home because we didn't have
Crispin Glover back for this one there
was a dispute amongst the the contractor
the salary and so we don't get him and
so it's just it's a little odd I thought
that Robert zemeck has handled it
brilliantly as far as making a movie and
having to go around as crucial of a
piece of the original Back to the Future
as George McFly was to be able to get
around that as well as he did I thought
is just a testament to him as a
filmmaker and then we spend the rest of
the movie going back to 1955 and just
sort of looking at the original events
through a fun house mirror and I love
that knowing that we get back to the
future three I think that Back To The
Future Three made that scene better
because without Back To The Future Three
then back to the future too the whole
thing just becomes sort of an exercise
in redundancy right yeah when I saw Max
feature 2 they had the during the
credits a ad for Back to the Future
three right I remember that and uh and I
think that is important uh because it's
kind of I guess I mean it was supposed
to be one movie and they kind of split
it into two and then you watch it you
kind of go I think it actually is just
one like you know what I mean like and
they both Back To The Future Three is
missing is probably in Back to Future
two and vice versa
um and look I loved uh it's so hard to
make a sequel it's so hard to keep a
world alive and they really did it but I
guess yeah I wish they'd from everything
you just said I wish they worked out
their salary thing with uh with Crispin
Glover uh just because
I think he you really that's the story
you're really actually kind of watching
that and they had to figure something
else out I guess I love that old west
stuff though I mean the old west is and
and it becomes more of Doc Brown's story
than anybody else you know I mean we
want Marty to get back to his normal
time period but just seeing Doc in an
actual relationship and like seeing
doctor be happy it's it it throws your
mind for a loop but it also adds another
layer to the character where he's not
just this mad scientist who has all
these weird Contraptions from time
travel to dog food machines he actually
does have a heart and I think that he
earned getting to fall in love with
someone to the level of a Mary's Dean
virgin because he he worked hard for
this he had to go to multiple time
periods but he finally did it but here's
the question does it make sense for a
matter of science like talk to actually
skew the future like that and fall in
love with somebody from the old way well
she was dead that's the only reason it's
okay
in the past she went off the cliff and
died so she's like a free agent now I
guess so I mean I can't do it with
someone who was gonna live no no because
that would have yeah the whole
space-time continuum thing it makes me
nervous but again it doesn't really
factor into particularly the first Back
to the Future because it's such a fun
ride and then the other two I think more
than anything for me it just it's just
getting to go back to that Universe
where even if it doesn't live up to the
legacy of the first movie just getting
to spend more time in that world is
always a treat so if they're on TV I'll
find myself watching them to conclusion
just because I I just love this world so
much yeah I feel the same way I uh I I
like the swings they took I mean I heard
zemeka say once they were going to make
it either way so it was either they were
gonna make it or someone else was gonna
make it and I'm glad they made it but
that first film in its construction is
so perfect it probably shouldn't have
had a sequel like it's just you you
can't I don't think anyone could make a
sequel that's better or even as good
it's just it it's like it's like telling
a perfect joke or something like you
know everything connects to everything
else and then at the end they got this
great gag where they go to the future
but you don't see it I mean it's just
like
such a perfect movie uh and I you know
my hat's off to them for trying and I I
look I loved it going back into that
world and spending time with those
characters but I man I'll I'll never
make something that great but if I did I
hope I stop you know what I mean
yeah you hope you could just kind of you
know put the brakes on when you need to
because the end of the first movie which
is another fun fact that I'm sure you're
already aware of is that in the
theatrical release version the Topher
got to see when he was a kid it did not
have like the the the DeLorean takes off
and goes into the future where we're
going we don't need roads and they shoot
out it was just everyone like laughed in
the audience and then it went into the
credits and then when it came out on VHS
it said to be continued they added it to
be continued which was so exciting for
me the first time I saw it it was like
oh my God this is we get more of this
but it's such a perfect way to end like
you said if you don't have the the
sequels if you just had that movie it
just lets us all use our imagination so
I think I know the answer to this
question as I'm asking it but is there
any way that you could ever reboot or
remake Back to the Future or is it just
one of those movies that we leave from
1985 in the Smithsonian for all time it
cannot be touched uh well I would
totally say don't touch it but I think
zemeka's got the rights by doing the
second two he the reason we haven't seen
four five six and seven is because
and Bob Gale
uh can control whether that happens or
not
and then it's probably up to their kids
when they go
whether it happens
um man it's so funny the way you're
talking about just the sequels to the
first one is kind of a metaphor for how
Hollywood is with IP or intellectual
property which is that people just want
to see the car like they just you know
anything that can
um look and this is coming from someone
who just did an episode of that 90s Show
on Netflix you know like everyone wants
to
uh be a part of something or or uh you
know be you know the Star Wars movies
keep rebooting there's like a everyone
wants to go back in the Millennium
Falcon or everyone wants to uh I get it
I want to go back but um I think what
you really want to do is see the
original movie again like you know what
I mean like truly you should go back and
watch that that first Star Wars Trilogy
or whatever but what I like doing
sometimes is just watching the trailer
for a secret yes like what I would love
to do if I could control what my kids
watch which I won't be able to do I
would say like um you know watch uh
Spider-Man one and two and and watch the
the trailer for Spider-Man 3 or whatever
you know what I mean like just uh
because the trailer is the the real
dream of what it could be and then it's
very hard slash maybe impossible when
something's so good to uh
I remember watching Iron Man one and
being like this is like a perfect movie
watching the trailer for Iron Man 2 and
being like oh here we go and I you know
oh no I'll tell you the best one ever
was Crystal Skull I was a good one I
mean I'd still go back and watch that
trailer from the late 2000s as the great
trailer moment of my love that I get to
geek out about trailers with you for a
sec here too because and it does pertain
to the Back to the Future conversation
oh yeah you're talking about teasers
right now I mean two and three were
filmed back to back and like Topher said
maybe it could have been one movie it
could have been split into two but
seeing that trailer was first of all it
was it was a bold step forward the first
movie has the greatest teaser of all
time that wasn't even in the film where
he's just walking up to the yeah okay
but the second one when he goes it's
like they're showing shots of the first
one oh my God it's so great and then he
goes are we back we're back like I mean
you just want to be part of something
where
gosh you're in a trailer like that it's
just oh my God the posters remember the
poster said uh
it's about time what a great yes because
it had been such a long time they took a
real break in between the two
also it's like the same day but Marty's
like you know six years older yeah it's
it yeah it's it's so it's just so funny
to look back on that and like look at
the excitement of that because I still
today like if I'm on the road and I'm
bored I'm more often than not after the
shows I'll put on like the Star Wars
trailers and just watch those because it
reminds me how excited I was to see
which ones are you talking about because
the force awakens has some of the
greatest trailers ever made the force
awakens trailer made me literally cry
when I was at um whatever this at Star
celebration in 2015. we have in the
premiere next week we go to Disneyland
but in it we see I mean there's like a
deep cut trailer nerd joke in the but we
like my brother reveals the Millennium
Falcon to me and it by the way it was
filming there it was like it's amazing
production value like it's very hard to
even though we're at ABC it was very
hard to get into the park and you get
Lucas film to sign off on it right right
cool stuff with Marvel to sign off but
like he reveals it to me and I go Chewie
we're home
[Laughter]
I'm like I don't know who's gonna get
this but to me that moment when uh
Harrison Ford said that those trailers
are amazing okay I'm gonna go best
trailers dude let's just abandon the
Back to the Future thing and I'm gonna
do best trailers of all time this is why
we're here I want to do with you you go
first like literally your favorite five
the best trailer and I'm not saying this
just because you're the guest and you
have some history with a certain edit of
this film I still go back to the first
teaser trailer and I'll and I'll I'll
I'll put you in in the room where I was
Topher I was watching The Siege I was a
freshman I bought a ticket to the siege
just to watch The Phantom Menace trailer
after I saw this on my roommate's
computer at the time there was some some
Pirate At the beginning of the internet
right yeah because I was like I was like
out drinking with my buddies in another
room my roommate comes to get me he
knows what a big Star Wars nerd I am by
this time and he's like dude you gotta
come check this out and I'm looking at
his computer screen on his laptop and
it's not full screen we don't know how
to do that yet it's just a tiny little
bar but he plays it and I see the
lucasfilm logo and I hear cheers and I'm
like what is this and I'm like no and
then you know every myth has every
Journey has the first step and then you
hear the Darth Vader breath and I'm like
good God and then I rush out and I buy a
ticket to Meet Joe Black is the movie I
went to go see I Saw The Siege and
didn't even stay to watch The Siege I
took off as soon I did not Meet Joe
Black that night I bought a ticket I did
not remember everyone this is like in
Westwood when I went to see it
everyone's waving their lightsabers and
then the Lucas film things up and
everyone gets dead silent like zero
cheers like people are just like trying
to ingest it it's great okay so that's
great that's one keep going what else
all right this one is a movie that maybe
most people don't remember but I'm
telling you the trailer was great thanks
to legendary rock band The Who
um there's a movie starring John
Leguizamo called Summer of Sam and the
movie itself go watch the silver Sam
trailer it's great the movie
the movie trailer is one of the best
Trails trailer wow great call man that's
a real that's a deep cut yeah so I went
I went easy front of the shelf and then
I went back to the back to the stock
room what is it okay let me give it a
shot
front shelf I'm gonna put all Spielberg
teasers so like
he has always does he's the only one
with his balls to do like zero footage
from the movie so it's like Jaws is
great where they're swimming around and
that voice is talking to you yeah
um E.T and and uh
uh Close Encounters have one but they're
a little generic uh Jurassic Park has an
amazing one this guy's just going deep
deep into a mine and he finds the bug in
Amber and he's looking at it and it goes
all the way into the bug's eye and I
mean it's like incredible
um and hook actually has a cool one too
um so I love all those ones because they
just have the balls not to to show any
of the actual footage from the movie
um Ghostbusters too
like clearly they've given them stock in
the film or something because like they
have a scene that could only really be
for the trailer but it's in the movie
where there's uh you know oh man I
forget what the setup is but it's Bill
Murray going um the one the only like
you know Ghostbusters and Dan actually
goes back and you're like well I don't
know why you'd have that in a movie but
it goes into the Ghostbusters theme and
it's unbelievable
um Ghostbusters 2 by the way sort of the
same you know DNA as Back to the Future
two and three where I really like that
movie there's a lot to take it's like a
kind of a retread but also really great
and they have the same cat all right so
my back shelf one yeah I don't know how
back shelf this is but um stranger
things season two so stranger things was
a big hit
and then the season two one has a uh
teaser cut to Thriller and it's so well
thought out and and it's about Halloween
but it's Thriller and it's the 80s and
they're the Ghostbusters it's like if
you want to get hyped go oh you know
what I'll tell you the best trailer I've
probably ever seen was this Marvel
celebrate the movie trailer that came
out in the middle of the pandemic do you
remember this the Marvels celebrate the
movies I was like it wasn't about one
movie it was like hear all the movies
coming out the next year or something oh
yeah and they had someone
you know it's by the way same composer
as uh Back to the Future Alex Allen
Sylvester yeah and they they did like
some hyped up version of it they're just
showing film after film and I was like I
gotta like close my computer like I just
got way too hyped like so good
especially during the pandemic like I
watched so many trailers and I got hyped
and I'm like well I'm still just
marrying the dog here you know but it's
I'm glad you actually brought up
Sylvester too because you can't really
talk about Back to the Future without
getting into how great that musical
score is I mean I think it's probably
the best I put it up there with the best
of John Williams and I put John Williams
as the greatest movie composer of all
time so the the adventures no you're
right there's really not a lot going on
in Back to the Future that's what makes
the score so amazing that it's you know
it kind of takes place in a couple
different rooms in this town square it's
not like uh the desert you know or for
some you know the ocean or something but
we're racing and and that makes it the
music that kicks in when he's driving
the car when he's driving the door and
makes it feel like we're going even
faster than we already are and the the
the the great scene that is particularly
touching to my Van Halen loving heart is
the Darth Vader scene where he puts the
tape that says Edward Van Halen they had
to write Edward because Van Halen the
band didn't sign off on it was just
Eddie so they had to write Edward and
that actually is Eddie Van Halen playing
guitar in that scene it's it's not a Van
Halen song it's an outtake because he
was doing the soundtrack for the
Wildlife and so it's an outtake that
didn't make it on that soundtrack oh is
that true it wasn't for back the two I
didn't know that yeah I'll tell you the
thing I watched the deleted scenes when
they all came out in that I think it was
like somewhere around 2000 they put them
all out and it was incredible like I've
never seen him was he chloroforms him at
the end and they kind at that part
that's why because you go I was always
like how did he get out of that room and
he chloroforms and it wasn't very
cinematic or great to watch and a little
bit questionable and that's why George
starts off the next scene saying I slept
late
I slept late anyway and he's like all
right get your stuff together yeah Darth
Vader said he was going to come down
from planet bulk and melt my brain
um just uh just another day in 1955.
well I I do want to get into some home
economics talk too because this is the
show I know it's been a passion project
like he already talked about getting to
produce it now and getting to have a say
in the cast I mean what did I guess what
do you do with this season that you're
excited about that maybe you didn't get
a chance to do with the previous
episodes you know it's we have some cool
plot stuff we have a flashback episode
so we did a little time travel we go to
it's funny it takes place in 2009 which
I was like wasn't that
like two weeks ago but uh you know Jimmy
who's my younger brother on it is um you
know just turned 30 and so 2009 for him
was like high school and it's great when
you start to like everyone's living like
we're wearing Live Strong bracelets and
you know someone's got like a team
Edward shirt on and like it's just it
was interesting to do a time period
thing about that
um it's about how we all met and all
that stuff but um there's stuff like
that but we find out we have a new
sibling which is you know the whole show
is about us as siblings and in a really
funny cool way we find out we have
another sibling which is big for us but
truly the plot isn't what you get
excited about as you go of the cast I'm
the one who's been on a show before and
yeah list too but like what happens is
you get into season three and four which
is when uh 70 shows started working when
a lot of sitcoms started kind of click
in is you there's like an idea of what
the show can be and you're casting to
that and the writers are writing to it
but then
then you all spend a lot of time
together and the writing gets better for
the characters and the actors get better
to the writing and the editing gets
Tighter and just everyone starts to know
what it the it is and uh actually it's
just fantastic it's just better I don't
know how to describe I wouldn't
if someone said walk me through 70 Show
seasons I wouldn't be like well this
season this plot thing happened that's
what made it better it's just that
everyone gets better and more of like a
tighter team unit and it's great to be
on something long enough to watch that
happen because it just gets so
what people remember of sitcoms I think
is the middle of their run but you can
then apply it to the first like I
Remember Loving friends the first season
it started but really what I loved was
the middle of friends and you kind of
when you're watching reruns you apply it
to the the beginning it's that's an
interesting point is because I'm
re-watching cheers right now um because
it's cheers and it's and it's great and
the first season is is so great but it's
also clearly sort of the setup for all
of the greatness that is to come and
then by the end of a Show's run it's
sort of like you know you don't want to
make the goodbye too long and so it
really is the the middle the the meat
and the sandwich that is the best stuff
in a sitcom yeah it's funny it's kind of
like this with these superhero movies
where the first one you have to learn
how the person got their powers and
multiple situation and the second one's
the one where you're like well we can
just like rock and roll now like you
don't have to like set a lot of stuff up
you can just have fun you know front to
back and I think that's what it feels
like here just each episode I don't know
I just you know I obviously I love
editing so much and getting things as
tight as possible and it just feels so
good I just I love the cast so much and
I love doing the job but I also love
watching it too I guess I'm getting high
on my own Supply yeah but I mean you
know you look at your career and and you
go all the way back to That 70s Show and
it feels like yesterday probably to to
you and me but it was a minute ago and
oh yeah it's the worst when young people
come to me they're like man I grew up
my mom used to if I finish my homework
my mom used to let me watch it I'm like
what aren't I your age what's the what's
can you distill it down to like one or
two you know lessons because you're
still you're great on the show but
you're still you're a young actor and
you're you're finding your way is
lessons for actors you're saying yeah
that you now apply as both an actor and
a producer on home economics well I you
know it's no secret that probably anyone
who's listening to your show knows that
I absolutely love editing and think and
just worship great editors and uh what
that meant to me when I was younger was
I didn't realize we're doing a four
camera they do edit four camera shows
but a lot of the editing
um like I did a play a couple years ago
and I'd never been on stage before and I
realized oh you're kind of doing post
uh while you're rehearsing it like
before you you know what I mean because
you gotta cut you gotta cut you got to
tighten certain things and then I
thought oh this is a little bit what 70
show was like because you're live in
front of an audience what you see you
know when the episode is done is pretty
similar to what you did that one night
you performed for the audience and then
as I've just gotten more into stuff
that's more filmic and obviously home
economics is a One camera show it's more
like a film I've just become more and
more obsessed with
post and the post process and how
how the audience uh views certain cuts
and certain rhythms as being
um because it's invisible editing is
invisible to people they don't know what
it is I actually it's funny I'm you're
right I did I've done a couple cuts of
films this is for me to learn how to
edit I basically gave bad notes on my
first film that I produced and was like
I bought an avid and just wanted to
learn how to
like what I did wrong basically but what
I became obsessed with is I mean people
know I talk about it a lot on a show
like this it's fine for me to talk about
it
um and I should say to any directors I'm
working with in the future I don't want
to edit things I'm in but uh
but I do have such a respect for it but
it's funny when it's when it's really
good you don't know that it's happening
it's a very invisible art form so I the
lesson for me was to understand that and
respect it and and understand how it the
thing moves you know under the surface
and it probably speaks to your love of
trailers too it's because that's taking
so much footage and being able to edit
it and condense it and just make it show
us the most exciting Parts like for
example but that's actually that's all
it ever is is
um it's it's curating yeah it's a museum
of you spent all this time amassing all
this stuff and then it's curating
just the best of I mean I'm always uh
our episodes are always a little short
there's like you know ABC should be
stoked there's always like time for one
more ad during our episodes
and and just think about that everybody
listening to everybody watching right
now
um think about that fact that Topher
brought up earlier talking about the
original Back to the Future How It took
an Editor to convince Robert zemeckis to
leave the Johnny B good scene at the
enchantment under the sea Dance that
movie here's how great the movie is it's
still a great movie without that scene
but it makes it that much better well
the lesson there is that the best thing
about editing is I I love acting but and
acting as a team sport uh but editing is
really a team sport because no you you
kind of can't do it without feedback of
others and you lose your way
um so it's very very valuable who you
edit it with
um that is uh it's a pretty good it's a
pretty good life lesson there kids be
careful who you edit with um Topher it's
been a pleasure I could literally talk
to you about trailers all day I know man
we just gotta do this uh about have no
subject matter and just go just trailer
park with my
that's another good one the original
time I don't know if I've seen that
trailer because it takes it's like
old-timey Universal and then um and then
all of a sudden like Van Damme walks
through the the portal thing and he
confronts his old partner oh dude okay
so you gotta watch Summers Sam
time cup the first time cop trailer I'm
cop all right yeah
what are you watching like
honey I had a visit with myself on his
podcast I saw me from the future right
he told me to watch time cop right
speaking of a great podcast everybody
out there you all should uh also check
out the minor Adventures of Topher Grace
uh hosted of course by Topher Grace he
gets into a lot of fun stuff with a lot
of his celebrity Pals and obviously home
economics back for another season check
out all of his wonderful library of
movies and TV shows it was a pleasure
having me man I'm really having you here
it's really really fun your your
favorite Back to the Future quote can uh
can take us out
uh listen doc are you telling me
and she built a time machine
kind of a DeLorean
[Music]
God what a pleasure talking to a guy I
mean you think you know a lot about Back
to the Future I know a lot about it but
Topher Grace uh a certified expert in
obviously the worlds of acting and
editing but also Back to the Future
knowledge that guy is second to none so
thanks again to Topher make sure y'all
check out the new season of home
economics where he is both an executive
producer and a star thank you so much
this was a a very um seminal day in the
history of the podcast and it was great
having Topher on um bum Jacqueline
missed it but I'm glad that now we get
that screenshot of just me
and me together again at last uh thanks
for tuning in to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong for Topher Grace for Brian Perez
for producing Lucy Jacqueline Coley and
the whole gang here at Rotten Tomatoes I
and Mark Ellis saying that if you didn't
enjoy this version of the podcast your
kids are gonna love it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]